Salut,
Je m'appelle Fabien Olicard.
Dans ce format nous abordons
un point en particulier sur notre cerveau.
Dans les épisodes précédents,
vous nous avez proposé d'aborder
notre côté, sens contre-intuitif.
C'est le sujet du jour,
bienvenue dans Matière grise.
[Musique]
Dans cet épisode, nous allons vivre
cinq expériences.
Expérience 1, à l'équilibre.
Expérience 2, les magiciens
ont tout compris.
Expérience 3, les pires statistiques.
Expérience 4, c'est à vous.
expérience 5, les bulles diaboliques.
Le tout avec la présence
très appréciée de Pierre Croce.
[Musique]
Nous l'avons vu dans
les épisodes précédents,
notre cerveau contient beaucoup
de données sur le monde
et essaye en permanence d'anticiper
ce qui pourrait nous arriver.
Il le fait pour les situations
que nous vivons.
Mais également pour le monde physique,
qui nous entoure et ses règles universelles.
Pourtant sur quelque chose
de si simple que la gravité,
il peut faire preuve d'une logique ou
d'un raisonnement contre-intuitif.
Vous allez voir,
c'est très perturbant.
Pierre, pour la première expérience,
on va faire une expérience sur la gravité.
- Très bien, ça me va.
- C'est pas la gravité
de "c'est pas fun"
- Non, c'est la situation, d'accord.
- Voilà, ce qui tombe.
Et ça a un nom ça d'ailleurs,
les expériences qu'on va faire
s'appellent la tenségrité.
- La ?
- La tenségrité.
- C'est québécois ?
- Alors, c'est pas québécois
mais j'ai demandé à Luc Langevin,
comme il est spécialiste de ça
et qu'il est québécois.
- Okay.
- De nous mettre au défi de faire
un truc de tenségrité,
pour qu'on voit
un peu ce que c'est.
Salutation à vous deux
Pierre et Fabien,
j'ai une petite démonstration
à vous montrer.
Démonstration, qui implique
une ceinture,
une simple ceinture comme ça
et une cuillère.
Une cuillère qui a été déformée de cette
façon avec le globe retourné, à 180°
Une légère courbure, d'environ 30 degrés
dans le manche, ici, comme ça.
Vous serez probablement
d'accord pour dire,
que si je tiens la cuillère entre
mon pouce et mon index, ici.
Si je lève mon index.
Eh bien la cuillère va basculer
et tomber au sol.
Démonstration.
ça s'appelle la gravité.
- C'est facilement non ?
Je peux le refaire à tout moment.
- Là, il y a peut-être une suite.
Et intuitivement, vous serez
probablement d'accord pour dire
que si on ajoute du poids
sur le bout de la cuillère,
comme si par exemple on ajoute
la ceinture comme ça.
Eh ben ça devrait pas
changer la démonstration.
Et c'est là qu'on fait erreur,
puisque lorsqu'on ajoute la ceinture,
Non seulement on peut lever l'index,
vous remarquez que la cuillère
est en équilibre,
sur le bout de mon doigt.
Et en fait, c'est parfaitement
stable comme structure.
Pierre, Fabien, je vous mets au défi
de reproduire cette expérience,
de faire vos premiers pas,
dans ce qu'on appelle, la tenségrité.
- Tu vois, c'est ce que j'avais dit.
- Tenségrité, en fait.
- La "tenségrité"
- Ah oui, d'accord.
- Des ceintures.
On en a, grosse production.
- Super.
- Des cuillères, en veux tu, en voilà.
- Là c'est chacun pour soi ?
- Je sais pas, non.
On n'est pas obligés d'être dans...
Par contre regarde, ça c'est
des cuillères spéciales.
C'est-à-dire que si tu frottes
comme ça,
elle va se tordre toute seule.
C'est incroyable ou pas ?
Non mais, il faut qu'on y arrive.
En fait c'est pas un battle,
c'est de la coop.
Il faut que un de nous deux y arrive.
- c'est pas du tout la même forme, non ?
C'est pas un carré qu'il faut faire,
c'est pas un rectangle.
Evidemment, après on donnera les cuillères
à cuillères sans frontières.
- Qui récoltent toutes
les cuillères d'expériences...
Attends, mais je pense
c'est un peu pareil non ?
Que ce soit comme ça,
mais oui c'est large.
- C'est plus ça, quand même.
- Non mais c'est pareil, de toute façon,
c'est une histoire d'équilibre, regarde.
Tu fais ça.
- Ouais.
ça pour l'instant,
il avait fait pareil.
- Pareil, et regarde maintenant,
centre de gravité.
Pourquoi ? C'est parce que...
La cuillère va rajouter du centre
de gravité vers l'intérieur du bras.
- "Du centre de gravité", mais tu utilises
un vocabulaire qui était étranger.
Mais c'est pas mal en vrai.
- ça y est c'est fait, en fait.
- Là, on est plus bons.
- Ouais.
Et je pense que toi, c'est parce que
que tu as fait ton pli là,
un peu plus loin.
- Ah je sais, je sais, je sais.
Il faut que tu essaies de mettre
ta cuillère dans ma boucle.
Tu vois ?
- C'est une image ?
- D'abord ta cuillère et après
la ceinture dans la cuillère.
- Ah !
- Là...
ça tient nickel !
- C'est bien.
Je pense que
l'expérience 1 est validée.
- Validée, merci Luc
- Merci Luc !
Okay, lui en vrai,
là il nous a fait un truc,
quand je lui ai demandé de
nous apprendre à faire ça
c'est parce que je l'avais vu
dans une émission
où il apprenait ça pour les enfants.
- D'accord, niveau CP, quoi.
- On est pas mal nous, là dessus.
Mais je l'ai vu faire
des espèces de happening,
hyper impressionnants,
de ce côté-là.
[Musique]
Et il fait plein de figures comme ça,
mais c'est juste impressionnant.
- Et en plus, on dirait une œuvre d'art,
ce qu'il a fait.
Bravo à lui.
Voilà Pierre, tu as découvert
la tenségrité.
- Merci pour la tenségrité.
- La "tenségrité".
Ce que nous venons de voir avec Luc,
ça s'appelle la tenségrité.
C'est l'étude des forces physiques
qui permet de faire tenir
de manière complètement
contre-intuitive
des ponts, ou simplement
de quelques lego.
Mais comment est-ce que
ça fonctionne vraiment ?
La raison pour ça,
c'est parce que on est habitués
de voir des structures
avec leur centre de gravité,
des différents éléments alignés.
Comme si on veut empiler un
téléphone portable et une bouteille d'eau.
La façon intuitive de le faire,
c'est d'aligner les deux objets.
Donc le centre de
gravité du téléphone,
aligné avec le centre de gravité
de la bouteille.
Mais si on veut faire une structure
un peu plus intéressante, avec ça.
Ce qu'on peut faire c'est par exemple
essayer de mettre le téléphone,
désaligné par rapport
au centre de la bouteille, comme ça.
Evidemment une structure
comme ça, c'est pas stable.
Si j'enlève ma main,
le téléphone va tomber.
Mais si on avait construit
le téléphone de façon,
à ce qu'il y ait un poids très lourd
à la base du téléphone, juste ici.
A ce moment là,
la structure serait stable
et ferait usage de ce qu'on appelle,
la tenségrité.
Bon il y a d'autres façons aussi, que
la répartition des poids pour obtenir ça.
On peut jouer avec le design
des objets aussi.
Un objet comme un verre est un objet
qu'on est habitué de voir debout
mais en changeant sa forme,
son design, en l'ajustant.
On peut faire tenir cet objet là,
dans une position qui est
plus contre-intuitive.
On peut réaliser la tenségrité
avec des éléments,
vraiment de  différentes formes
mais c'est toujours plus impressionnant
de le faire avec des objets usuels,
parce qu'on donne l'impression
de connaître ces objets là.
Et lorsqu'on réussit.
Eh bien ça s'apparente
pratiquement à de la magie.
Un grand merci à Luc Langevin
pour son intervention.
Je vous invite à le suivre sur
tous ses réseaux sociaux
où il fait souvent des démonstrations
un peu folles de tenségrité.
Je vous recommande également de
vivre l'expérience de son nouveau projet,
un spectacle digital à distance,
complètement novateur.
Vous avez les infos en lien
dans la description.
En parlant de magicien, je vais vous
faire voir un tour de magie
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
il fonctionne contre votre intuition.
Salut, jeune entrepreneur du cerveau !
Toi aussi tu veux réfléchir
mieux et plus vite
et divertir ton esprit,
en apprenant, tout en rigolant ?
Eh ben c'est possible !
et c'est maintenant
et c'est avec Fabien Olicard.
Avec son spectacle d'humour
et de mentalisme dans toute la France,
en tournée même aussi
en Belgique et en Suisse
et surtout au zénith de Paris,
Le 20 novembre.
Tu vas avoir les neurones,
ils vont pétiller comme des pop-corn
parce que que tu vas
beaucoup rigoler
et surtout, tu vas avoir
du mentalisme.
Et ça, c'est bluffant et même toi
peut-être tu vas te bluffer.
Utilise Fabien Olicard,
c'est du mentalisme à l'état pur
et c'est en spectacle,
en tournée dans toute la France
mais surtout au zénith de Paris,
le 20 novembre.
ça va être incroyable pour toi.
- Parce que toutes les informations
sont dans la description.
- "But I wasn't talking..."
- Oui, mais si je traduis, je suis obligé
d'attendre que tu parles pour traduire.
Sinon on va voir que
je traduis de la merde.
"In the description".
- Dans la description.
- Traduis bien là.
- Oui, mais là, je l'ai fait en français...
fin c'est bizarre.
- Ouais, non mais c'est bien.
[Musique]
Tout à l'heure nous allons faire
des expériences de physique,
dont le résultat
va nous surprendre.
C'est à dire, vous surprendre
et me surprendre, moi aussi.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que notre cerveau contient des
schémas qu'il croit comme étant vrais.
L'intuition, c'est la somme de toutes
les expériences que nous avons vécues,
traitées par notre esprit
pour établir des règles,
qu'il considère comme
étant la vérité.
Les magiciens, ils exploitent
ces raccourcis du cerveau,
ces raccourcis de l'intuition,
et surtout, ces failles que
nous avons tous en commun
pour mieux réussir
à nous surprendre.
La fin d'un tour de magie, ce n'est pas
ce que notre intuition avait prévu,
du coup on est bluffés.
Là, pour la suite.
Bon comme tu sais, c'est la vidéo
sur les trucs un peu contre-intuitifs
et il y a un truc qui est hyper
contre-intuitif, c'est le bonneteau.
L'idée, c'est que tu prends
par exemple,
une rouge et deux noires, tu vois.
Tu dis, la carte gagnante
c'est la rouge par exemple.
Donc je mets
la rouge au milieu.
Là, je te fais pas le tour,
c'est juste pour expliquer pour ceux
qui connaissent pas.
Mais tu as une noire, une noire.
Ici tu as une rouge.
T'as la rouge, t'as la rouge
et il te ferait ça, tu vois.
Il dirait, où est la rouge,
par exemple?
Et elle est ?
- Moi j'ai suivi et elle est là.
Elle est exactement pas là tu vois,
ça va très très vite le bonneteau.
- D'accord.
- Voilà ça, c'est la même chose
mais sans gobelet.
- J'étais sur de moi.
- Ouais, je sais, c'est normal.
- Je peux essayer ?
- Ouais, vas-y.
- C'est bon t'as suivi ?
- Non mais je ne sais pas encore
où est la rouge.
- Ah je t'ai pas montré ?
Elle est là.
- Okay.
C'est si nul.
- Alors ?
- Mais même là
je crois que je l'ai.
Ah non putain.
- Ah tu vois ?
Alors en fait, pourquoi ça marche
contre notre intuition ?
Parce que ça exploite certaines failles
de ce que tu crois avoir perçu
et ce que tu crois voir
comme logique.
Tu vois les passes très classiques,
t'as la rouge, la noire et la rouge, okay.
Ici, au milieu,
on met la noire, okay ?
- Je peux vérifier ?
- Tu vérifiera que c'est faux.
- Ah oui déjà ?
C'est très fort.
- Ce qui est fou c'est que là
je t'ai l'attention dessus,
mais si on en avait pas parlé, si on avait
fait ça juste en discutant comme ça.
T'as pas forcément
de doute pour le cerveau.
Parce qu'elle est vraiment là.
- Et pourquoi ça, ça fonctionne
en contre-intuition ?
Je te le dis à la fin,
dans quelques secondes.
- Okay.
- Je vous en parle,
mais juste après.
Tu sais pourquoi ?
- Vas-y.
- Pour qu'ils restent.
- C'est fort ça.
- Je te fais un bonneteau hyper
contre intuitif et rapide quand même.
On joue contre l'intuition.
- D'accord.
- Donc méfie toi de ton intuition.
On met la carte noire au milieu.
- Déjà là...
- Ton intuition te dit, il a triché.
- Ouais.
- Okay, mais elle est au milieu.
- Mais oui, d'accord.
- Et là du coup ton intuition,
te dit de me faire confiance.
- Non, jamais.
- Mais en fait j'ai déjà retourné.
Elle toujours au milieu,
- Ah bon ?
- Oui, oui.
- Quand ?
- Là maintenant.
Je te le refais, en plus long.
Je te mets une rouge
au milieu, okay ?
Ton intuition te dit quoi ?
- Elle est à l'envers par rapport
aux autres cartes ?
- Oui, elle est à l'envers,
ça c'est bon, okay.
- Mon intuition,
elle est basique.
Mais ouais elle est basique.
Par contre, ton intuition devrait
se fier à la règle de départ,
de la carte noire est
toujours au milieu, okay ?
Donc en gros tu as
une rouge et deux noires.
Non deux rouges
et une noire.
Attends, tu as un problème avec ça ?
- Oui.
- En fait tu as une carte noire,
deux cartes noires, trois cartes noires.
- J'ai l'intuition que tu es en train
de m'arnaquer là.
- Donc tu as trois cartes noires, c'est bon ?
- Ouais, okay.
- Sur le dessus, tu as donc...
- Noire.
- Une rouge.
Sur le dessous, tu as...
- Ouais, une carte.
- Une carte.
- Et au milieu
tu as la rouge, okay ?
Et là ton intuition...
- Il n'y a plus de noir là ?
- Si.
- Non.
Et ton intuition te dit,
elle est toujours au milieu.
- Non mais j'ai vu,
il y avait que des rouges.
- Non mais il y a une noire là.
Attends mais si la noire t'embête,
je l'enlève et c'est réglé.
Comme ça il nous reste deux cartes.
Un quatre et un six, okay ?
Là ton intuition elle dit, non.
Mais si, il y a deux cartes.
Et ton intuition de départ,
te rappelle qu'au départ,
il y a une carte noire,
au milieu de deux cartes rouges.
Okay.
- Comment ça s'appelle ça ?
Comment ça s'appelle ?
- Un "pento".
- Un "pento" ?
- C'est faible hein,
c'est pas très fort.
- c'est pas très fort...
- Mais c'est contre intuitif aussi.
- Tu dois trouver la carte.
- Laquelle ? Si c'est l'as, c'est bon.
- Oui, c'est l'as
Comment fonctionne ce truc,
c'est quand même fou.
Mais ton cerveau en fait,
il fait une impression rétinienne
de cette forme là.
Et se dit : "okay, ça c'est la logique".
- Il fait ça mon cerveau ?
- Ouais.
C'est la logique, c'est la règle.
ça veut dire que si on retourne tout,
ça doit avoir la même forme,
c'est logique c'est la règle.
En vrai, si on retournait
sans rien bouger, sans manipulation.
On devrait être dans cet état.
- D'accord.
- Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
- c'est dire notre cerveau,
il préfère une figure qui est fausse.
Il se dit : "ça c'est vrai".
Plutôt que la vraie figure
qui ferait ça, où il se dit :
"Non mais là c'est faux, c'est pas bon",
en fait, tu vois ?
Dans les années 1900
Arthur Good, alias Tom Tit,
proposait des expériences
en tant que magicien scientifique.
Son but, c'était d'émerveiller les gens
pour les amener à s'intéresser
aux sciences et à essayer
de les comprendre.
Il voulait perturber
leur confiance en leur intuition,
pour aiguiser leur esprit critique.
Depuis toujours, les magiciens s'intéressent
à l'intuition spontanée du cerveau.
Et même s'ils sont pas
chercheurs ou scientifiques.
Leurs expériences
nous sont toujours profitable.
Le moment où notre sens de l'interprétation
pose réellement problème,
c'est dans le traitement
de plusieurs données en même temps.
Le plus fréquent d'entre eux,
vient de notre interprétation
des statistiques,
comme on peut en avoir
par exemple par les médias.
On a beaucoup vu ça
ces derniers mois.
Toi même tu sais.
Sommes-nous vraiment
capables d'interpréter des statistiques ?
- Pierre Croce.
- C'est moi.
- De la chaîne Pierre Croce.
- Ouais exactement,
et Pierre Croce Volume 2,
j'ai deux chaînes.
- Oui c'est vrai.
- D'ailleurs, tu m'invites
en tant que Pierre Croce
ou en tant que
Pierre Croce Volume 2 ?
En tant que Pierre Croce volume 2,
parce que c'est moins cher.
- C'est vrai, j'avoue
c'est beaucoup moins cher.
- Est-ce que tu connais
l'illusion de corrélation
ou le biais de corrélation, d'ailleurs ?
- Ouais, c'est bon.
- C'est un truc ça,
ça va tu maîtrises ?
En vrai, ce sont des statistiques.
- Je peux me mettre comme ça ?
- Ouais bien sûr,
t'es bien dans le champ, c'est parfait.
ça a été un truc découvert en 1967
par Chapman et Chapman
et ils se sont aperçus que
en vrai on n'est pas capable
avec notre cerveau de lire
des statistiques, tu vois ?
On n'est pas capable
d'avoir le résultat.
- Pourquoi ils nous insultent ?
- On n'est pas capable de les comprendre.
- Non, non,
alors moi je peux.
- Tu vois ça c'est deux courbes,
de deux choses différentes.
- Ouais.
- Il y a une corrélation à 95%.
Est-ce que tu penses que
ces courbes sont liées
que l'une impact l'autre ?
- Alors, je pense que tu essayes
de me faire dire...
- Que oui... Que non.
- Que oui mais que c'est non,
et que finalement c'est oui.
- Donc pour toi c'est oui au final ?
- Et en fait, tu essaies
de me faire dire oui, mais c'est non.
- Donc toi là, c'est ton dernier mot,
c'est non  ?
- Ouais, c'est non.
- Sûr, sûr ?
- Les deux courbes ne sont pas liées.
- Et c'est vrai.
Elles ne sont pas liées, Pierre Croce.
Parce que sinon l'intérêt
de cette vidéo se perd totalement.
- Bien sûr.
- Donc la courbe verte, c'est l'importation
de pétrole aux Etats-Unis et en Norvège
- Et c'est mis en corrélation,
avec le nombre d'automobilistes décédés
en se prenant un train dans la gueule.
- D'accord, quasiment rien à voir
sauf si le train transporte des barils
de pétrole venant de la Norvège.
- Suivi par des petits malfrats,
en voiture qui veulent le voler
et qui du coup de n'évitent pas le train.
Donc année, par année,
on prend les chiffres,
on les compare et on s'aperçoit
qu'à 95% ça se suit.
Et ça c'est hyper fort,
c'est le genre de truc qu'ont démontré
Chapman et Chapman.
C'est à dire que là, okay,
on sait que ça n'a vraiment rien à voir,
mais si je te mets, je sais pas moi,
une maladie en ce moment
et un médicament lambda
qui se mettrait en ce moment,
on pourrait tirer
des conclusions, en se disant :
"c'est sûr ça marche,  mais on n'a pas
assez de données pour juger,
nous autres qui
ne sommes pas spécialistes".
- Mais si tu mets le petit schéma là,
aux infos et tu peux faire croire...
- Ouais, c'est ça ouais.
En fait j'en ai plein d'autres des comme ça,
qui sont très cools.
Là, j'ai le nombre de...
c'est très cool les gens
décédés par noyade.
- Par noyade après être tombés
d'un bateau de pêche, parfait.
- Tu vois ?
- Okay, pardon, j'ai rigolé
alors que franchement,
je compatie vraiment pour eux.
- Non mais c'est le kentucky
qui t'as fait rire, je crois.
- En plus.
Parce que en plus, c'est l'état du KFC,
moi j'imagine les mariages dans les KFC
- Toi, t'as vraiment beaucoup de références
liées à la nourriture, quand même.
- Au poulet, souvent.
- Donc plus il y a de gens
qui se marient dans le Kentucky,
on peut le voir, plus on a de personnes
décédées de noyade
après être tombées
d'un bateau de pêche.
- Moi c'est plus l'inverse que je vois.
Plus il y a de personnes
décédées de noyade, plus...
- On repeuple le Kentucky.
- Voilà, exactement.
- On va aller un peu plus loin, Pierre.
Il y a 1314 personnes,
des femmes exclusivement.
Qui ont été suivies
pendant 20 ans,
parce qu'on voulait...
c'est une vraie étude.
On voulait voir lesquelles avaient
le plus gros taux de mortalité.
Est-ce que c'était chez les fumeuses
ou chez les non fumeuses.
Et là, je te présente ce qu'on appelle
le paradoxe de Simpson,
c'est le résultat final,
qui va contre ton intuition sûrement,
puisqu'on voit que les fumeuses...
- Attends, c'est quoi ?
-  meurent moins.
- C'est le taux de mortalité
après 20 ans,
combien d'entre elles
sont mortes après 20 ans.
Et parmi ce combien d'entre elles,
combien étaient fumeuses
et combien étaient pas fumeuses.
- Mais au bout de 20 ans
ou après 20 ans, l'âge de 20 ans ?
- En fait, ils ont fait ça
après 20 ans
et ils ont suivi cette étude
pendant 20 ans.
- Donc il y a plus de morts
en non-fumeuses.
Donc fumez, vraiment
la cigarette quoi.
A fond, à fond, à fond.
- Mais ça c'est incroyable,
de se dire c'est ça les chiffres.
Et le paradoxe de Simpson, c'est que si
on prend maintenant les mêmes données,
tranche d'âge par tranche d'âge.
Donc, c'est la même étude que ça.
- D'accord.
- On voit que sur les 18-24,
c'est les fumeuses qui mouraient le plus.
Sur les 25-34, c'était à peu près équivalent
mais c'était plus
les non-fumeuses quand même.
Et après sur les 35-44,
c'était largement les fumeuses.
Ensuite largement les fumeuses,
largement les fumeuses,
largement les fumeuses.
Et là c'est ce qui nous met
dedans, d'ailleurs
C'est à peu près équivalent,
les plus de 75 ans.
On s'est aperçu qu'au dessus de 75 ans,
à un moment donné les gens meurent.
- D'accord.
- Parce que c'est 75 ans et plus.
Quand tu regardes ça, tu te dis toujours
c'est les fumeurs qui meurent le plus.
Et pourtant, si on cumule
toutes les données,
ça donne ça.
Où tu as l'impression que
c'est les non-fumeuses qui meurent le plus.
-  Alors là, je l'ai pas.
- T'as pas le truc qui te permet de la voir,
le truc qui permettrait de la voir,
c'est de savoir combien de personnes
ont été suivies dans cette tranche d'âge,
combien dans cette tranche d'âge,
combien dans cette tranche d'âge
et le fait est que là,
dans cette tranche d'âge
ils ont suivi beaucoup plus de
non-fumeuses que de fumeuses.
En gros là, je te donne
des chiffres au pif,
mais ils ont peut-être suivi
500 non-fumeuses, tu vois,
pour 15 fumeuses.
- Okay,
- Okay, donc quand tu fais ça,
ça nous fait le même truc,
mais quand tu additionnes
tous les chiffres,
du coup ça fait exploser
les non-fumeuses qui sont mortes
parce qu'elles étaient
beaucoup plus présentes ici, que ici.
Mais quand tu vois un truc comme ça,
paraître dans la presse,
ils vont te dire,
"c'est des vraies données, ça été vérifié".
- Par contre ça doit être un gros gros journal
parce que si ça c'est juste une page
- On a découpé les pages.
- ça c'est juste l'article
- C'était l'article.
- D'accord.
- Et ça ça s'appelle
le paradoxe de Simpson.
Et je vais vous expliquer un peu plus
longuement comment ça fonctionne.
- je pourrais regarder la vidéo ?
Parce que j'ai pas tout capté.
- Ouais, je te l'envoie après l'envoie après.
- Okay, merci.
Ce que nous venons de voir,
s'appelle le paradoxe de Simpson.
Pas Homer, évidemment mais bien
Edouard Simpson, un statisticien
qui en 1951 a démontré
nos conclusions intuitives erronées,
vis-à-vis des statistiques.
Depuis, on appelle ça
le paradoxe de Simpson
Voici une expérience simple,
qui vient d'une vraie étude.
Un exemple simple venant
d'une vraie étude,
montre que sur ces deux traitements
pour les calculs rénaux,
L'un est efficace à 79%,
alors que le deuxième l'est à 83%.
Et pourtant les chiffres
sont justes,
mais vous auriez peut-être intérêt
à opter pour le premier traitement.
Car si on segmente les résultats
avec d'autres critères,
il s'avère que le premier est efficace
à 93% pour des petits calculs,
contre 87% pour le deuxième.
Et le premier est efficace
à 73% contre les gros calculs,
contre 69% pour le deuxième.
Voilà le paradoxe,
si on segmente les résultats,
alors le premier traitement est toujours
plus efficace que le deuxième.
mais si on fait la synthèse
des résultats,
alors on a l'impression mathématique,
qu'au final le deuxième traitement
est le meilleur.
Pourquoi ça fait ça ?
Parce que le premier traitement
a été utilisé sur 87 personnes,
pour les petits calculs rénaux,
contre 270 personnes
pour le deuxième traitement.
Maintenant, prenons en compte que
ce sont les calculs les plus faciles à soigner.
Et inversement, le premier traitement
a été utilisé sur 263 personnes
pour les gros calculs,
contre seulement 80 personnes
pour le deuxième traitement.
Et ce sont les calculs
les plus difficiles à soigner.
Comme le total final a été
calculé avec tous les cas,
ils n'ont pas une moyenne des deux
statistiques que je viens de vous citer.
Alors on a une inversion des résultats.
C'est ce qui conduit au paradoxe.
Attention, c'est à vous !
Dans quelques instants,
je vais mettre votre sens intuitif
à l'épreuve.
Je vais vous poser six questions
mais faites attention.
Parmi elles,
il y en a qui sont cachées et qui ont
une réponse un peu contre-intuitive.
- Je peux buzzer sur le cerveau ?
- Ouais, ouais, sans problème.
- ça c'est quoi ?
Vas-y...
question, vas-y.
- Okay, question numéro 1.
c'est la plus dure.
Et l'expliquerai qu'à la fin.
Un agriculteur a 100 kg
de pommes de terre chez lui.
- Déjà bravo, parce qu'il bosse tout seul
et ça c'est toujours qu'il fait 100 kg ?
- il y a 100 kg de patates,
elles sont composées à 99 % d'eau
et 1% de matière sèche.
Il les laisse, il attend un peu,
l'eau s'évapore un peu,
du coup elles sont composées
à plus que 98 % d'eau.
Et du coup quel est
le poids des patates au final ?
- Mais il y a toujours 100 kg.
- Etaye ton propos.
- C'est le pourcentage qui a bougé,
mais ça veut pas dire que
la masse a bougé.
Je me souviens que c'est ça,
mais je sais pas l'expliquer en fait.
La pomme de terre...
- Attention, tu te transformes en Verrecchia
- La pomme de terre n'a pas
changé de poids, de matière.
Mais les 2% de matière
sont égales à 1 kg du début.
Parce que eux n'ont pas bougé.
- C'est exact.
- Donc ça fait plus que la moitié non,
c'est pas ça ?
Un truc comme 50 kg ?
- C'est exactement ça, bravo.
Bravo Pierrot.
Et les explications,
je vous les referai mieux à la fin.
- Non, elle était bien là.
- Quelle est la ville la plus au sud
entre New York et Rome ?
Tu vois là aussi, dans tes intuitions
tu connais la géographie.
- Alors, je vois que tu essaies de faire...
- Attention, il n'y a pas que
des réponses contre-intuitives
- Et là j'ai bien compris que c'était
encore un tour de manipulation,
un tour de passe passe.
Je dirais que c'est New York,
le plus au sud
- Exact. Correct.
Je sais pas si vous l'aviez aussi,
alors ça se joue à pas grand chose.
Là vous voyez peut-être
une image à l'écran, qui vous fait voir.
Mais c'est bien New York qui est
légèrement plus au sud que Rome.
Okay, question numéro 3.
Will Smith, est-il plus vieux
ou plus jeune
que l'oncle Phil à l'époque de la série ?
- Will Smith fait quand même
très jeune physiquement
alors qu'il commence à être vieux.
Donc je pense que Will Smith
actuellement est plus jeune
que l'oncle au Phil à l'époque.
- Eh ben non, Will Smith
est plus vieux.
- Oui c'est ça !
- Ouais mais...Non, non, non !
- C'est juste que
je me suis trompé de mot.
S'il te plait, c'était tout
mon fond de pensée.
Quatrième question.
On est sur un sans faute du "Croçosse".
- Aller.
Est-ce qu'il est possible,
c'est un oui ou non.
Qu'au moment de ta naissance, tu aies été
la personne la plus jeune de la planète ?
- Est-ce que quelqu'un,
qui est né prématurément,
est plus jeune que
quelqu'un qui est né
normalement au bout de 9 mois ?
Non tu nais à zéro.
- j'ai pas envie de commenter
cette logique.
- Bonjour, je m'appelle Pierre,
j'ai zéro seconde.
- Tu parles déjà
- Oui.
- Ce qui est quand même
assez prometteur pour le futur.
- j'ai zéro seconde actuellement,
personne n'a moins que zéro seconde.
- Donc ta réponse est oui ?
- Ouais.
- Ouais, c'est juste, ouais.
- C'est ça ?
C'était juste juste drôle de mettre
des questions comme ça
à un moment donné.
- D'accord, okay.
- Question numéro 5.
Quand star wars est sorti,
on guillotinnait encore des gens en France.
Vrai ou faux ?
- Je pense qu'on s'en servait plus,
mais que jusqu'à l'abolition
de François Mitterrand
qui arrive au pouvoir en 1981,
je sais pas quand
est-ce qu'il l'a abolie
parce qu'il a un peu bossé
sur le projet avant.
Et je pense qu'il y avait encore
la guillotine qui était dans les textes.
- Okay.
- mais plus utilisée.
- Donc c'est faux.
Pour le coup elle était dans les textes,
mais on s'en servait.
Ouais c'était en 1977, la dernière fois
qu'on a utilisé la guillotine
après la sortie de Star Wars.
C'est ouf ou pas ?
- C'est pas gentil ça.
c'est surtout que
c'est pas longtemps.
T'imagines moins de 10 ans
avant ta naissance,
on coupait encore des têtes en France.
- C'est triste.
A quel moment
il y a la plus grande distance
entre Cléopâtre et l'IPhone,
ou entre Cléopâtre et les pyramides ?
Et là tu dis : "ouais mais là
il veut m'avoir parce que...
mais en même temps comme c'est
la dernière que question, je sais pas.
Mais en même temps je sais pas".
Je te laisse réfléchir,
je vais boire un coup.
- C'est bon, moi j'ai ma réponse.
- T'as ta réponse ?
- Ouais, j'ai ma réponse.
Bon je dirais quand même
Cléopâtre-pyramide.
Contre-intuition.
- Donc toi, tu dis qu'il y a plus de temps
entre le début des Pyramides et Cléopâtre
que entre Cléopâtre et l'IPhone ?
- bah oui parce que là sinon
ta question est naze sinon.
Tu restes sur ton choix ?
- Ouais.
- Okay, tu as raison.
Il s'est passé plus de temps
entre le moment
où on a commencé à construire
les pyramides et Cléopâtre.
Cléopâtre techniquement,
sur une frise historique
elle est plus proche de l'iPhone
que des pyramides.
Voici donc des réponses
contre-intuitives.
Parce que notre cerveau ne prend pas
en compte toutes les données,
mais des sensations de données.
Pour cette histoire
de pommes de terre,
il fallait non pas se concentrer
sur la matière humide, l'eau
mais sur la matière sèche,
qui elle a un poids
qui ne change pas dans le temps.
Au départ on avait 100 kg
de pommes de terre,
pour 1 % de matière sèche.
Donc il y avait un kilo
de matière sèche.
A la fin il y a 2 % de matière sèche
ça fait toujours un kilo,
alors avec une simple règle de trois,
on sait qu'il reste 50 kg
de pommes de terre.
Et le pire, c'est que même
en le comprenant et en le calculant,
au fond de nous,
ça reste perturbant comme résultat.
On a vu plein de raisons
de nous méfier de notre intuition,
même avec des choses
aussi simples que la gravité.
Mais en creusant sur le sujet,
j'ai découvert des trucs
encore plus contre-intuitifs.
En fait ça va au delà du contre-intuitif,
au-dessus c'est...
ce que vous allez voir.
Voici une expérience de physique
amusante, contre intuitive.
Si je pousse fort ce pendule,
- Ouais.
- Qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
pour tout le reste d'après toi ?
Qu'est-ce que ton intuition
te dit sincèrement,
sans penser
à essayer de te dire :
"attends on est dans du contre-intuitif,
donc ça va faire ci ou ça".
- Ils vont se synchroniser.
- D'accord.
Alors première hypothèse,
ils vont se synchroniser.
Et j'ai une deuxième question,
- Ouais.
- lequel des deux s'arrêtera
en premier, d'après toi ?
- Alors s'ils sont synchronisés,
il s'arrêtent en même temps, non ?
Par définition.
- Okay.
Donc, ils vont se synchroniser
et s'arrêter en même temps.
- Ouais.
- Voici ce que nous dit Pierre.
Je te propose de le prendre
et de le jeter un petit peu.
- Je peux prendre celui-là ou
ça change rien ?
ça change quelque chose ou ?
- ça change parce que c'est pas ce que
j'avais prévu dans ma tête.
- D'accord.
- Mais je vois bien que
c'est très personnel.
Donc du coup tu peux le faire.
Okay.
ça bouge bien.
- ça peut faire tomber les pieds.
- Okay, alors est-ce qu'ils
vont se synchroniser ?
c'est la première question.
Eh bien, lui s'est arrêté
complètement.
Mais, ils repartent !
- ça reprend.
ça fait un mouvement perpétuel ?
- Et en fait lui,
s'est arrêté complètement.
Mais !
Et en fait, ils se transfèrent
l'énergie comme ça.
- Mais attends, est-ce que
ça s'arrête un jour ?
- Non et on vient de solutionner
le problème énergétique mondial.
ça va s'arrêter parce qu'en fait
dès que tu as un mouvement,
il y a une dépense d'énergie
de chaleur, de friction, etc.
Qui fait que ça peut pas
être perpétuel.
Mais en soit s'il n'y avait
pas de frottement,
s'il n'y avait pas de perte d'énergie,
ça continuerait éternellement.
- Tu savais que la formule du poids
c'est P = m.g ?
- Je te trouve
de plus en plus intelligent,
j'aimerais bien qu'on m'appelle
Pierre Croce, s'il vous plaît.
- ça pour le watch-time,
c'est excellent.
Surtout que la fin est folle.
Tu vas voir qu'à la 7ème minute..
- ça va vous surprendre.
Maintenant, on va passer à quelque chose
de beaucoup plus ludique, Pierre Croce.
- Pour l'instant,
c'est déjà très bien pour moi.
- Ecoute, on va faire des bulles.
- Ouais, on va faire des bulles.
- Oublions ça, faisons des bulles.
Une nuit, dans une pièce
remplie de bulles.
- Oui, okay.
- Okay.
- Pour faire des bulles, Pierre.
Pour faire des bulles,
il nous faut de quoi faire des bulles.
Pierre, je te laisse décapsuler
et tu mets là, n'en bois surtout pas.
- ça fait des bulles, Pierre ?
- Ouais.
- Okay.
En gros d'après toi,
si on le trempe entièrement,
si on trempe toutes les faces dedans,
ça va être quoi
la forme finale de la bulle ?
c'est-à-dire, comment va
se mettre le savon,
sur cette structure qui est
un quadrilatère de forme carrée.
- Ecoute moi bien, c'est censé...
- Sois pas si agressif
rejoindre tous les sommets,
ça va faire...
- Techniquement en vrai,
je peux dire que dans le résultat final
tous les sommets
sont effectivement joints.
- ça va faire coté, côté, côté.
mais à l'intérieur il va y avoir des...
Aussi ça je pense.
- Des diagonales.
On tente ?
- On tente.
comme on peut pas
le mettre en entier,
tu le tournes délicatement
sur toutes les surfaces.
- Et en fait, ça fait les diagonales
dont je te parlais...
- Et voilà.
- Mais pas les côtés.
- C'est incroyable ou pas ?
- C'est magnifique.
- Tu as un cube au centre.
Là c'est vide après, autour.
c'est fou !
- Et c'est en suspension totale ?
- C'est en suspension totale.
et en vrai c'est parce que le savon cherche
à utiliser le moins de surface possible,
pour toucher tous les côtés.
- Je te fais la tête pour la miniature.
- Et je rêvais de le faire,
donc j'écris tout une vidéo
prétexte à le faire.
- Attends, attends,
du coup avec la pince.
- Ouais.
Non, mais c'est parce qu'il faut
que la surface soit...
- Et voila.
- C'est beau, bravo Pierre Croce.
Monsieur Pierre Croce,
c'était un plaisir de vous avoir avec nous.
Merci d'être venu faire
ces expériences toute la journée.
- Merci Fabien, merci de me recevoir.
Merci à toute la chaîne
Fabien Olicard d'ailleurs.
Parce qu'on pense que
c'est qu'une seule tête,
mais il y a énormément de monde
derrière tout ça.
- Enormément de monde.
- Merci à toute l'équipe
- Merci Pierre,
- Merci à toi.
Contrairement à ce que croyait
notre intuition,
la nature ne cherche pas à faire joli
ou à remplir quoi que ce soit.
Au contraire, elle cherche à utiliser
le moins d'énergie possible
en minimisant au maximum
les surfaces qu'elle utilise pour la bulle.
En y réfléchissant, on comprend que
le moyen le plus simple
de relier plusieurs villes entre elles,
n'est pas de relier chaque
ville à une autre ville,
mais bien de faire partir
un chemin de chaque ville
qui va se rejoindre
en un carrefour commun.
C'était logique mais pas intuitif.
Merci à toute l'équipe
pour ce nouvel épisode,
merci à Fanny à la production,
à Loïc à la réalisation.
Merci aussi, à Pierre Croce,
avec qui je fais des enquêtes de couples
approximatifs, sur sa chaîne.
Je vous invite à regarder ses vidéos,
le lien vers sa chaîne
est dans la description.
Pensez à liker cette vidéo,
à vous abonner pour ne pas rater
les prochains épisodes
et tous les anciens épisodes
sont dans la description.
Alors sommes nous condamnés
à subir nos mauvaises intuitions ?
Faut-il au contraire les écouter ?
Existe-t-il des systèmes
pour empêcher notre cerveau
de faire les mauvaises hypothèses ?
Vous aurez la réponse
à ces questions et à bien d'autres,
dans les prochains épisodes
de Matière grise
A très bientôt.
Ciao !